wie einfach ist es eine wurst zu faken
mit ganz wenig fleisch viel wasser
schlachtabfällen und einigen weiteren
zwielichtigen zusatzstoffen und können
wir dann diese fake wurst auch noch mit
einem gütesiegel auszeichnen lassen
wir haben wirklich will ich diese
genommen das war ja keine wurf wir
machen das experiment mit eigener marke
einer eigenen gepanschten wurst und
unserem eigenen echten metzger das alles
um der frage nachzugehen wie viel abfall
ist in der wurst die wir kaufen
einige monate zuvor ein informant
schickt uns bilder
sie sollen fleischabfälle zeigen aus den
mittel hergestellt werden die dann in
die industrielle wurst kommt und der
verbraucher solle davon nichts erfahren
wir wollen herausfinden ob das stimmt
unser erster schritt wir gründen eine
scheinfirma mit eigenem büro und eigener
homepage
wir nennen uns in omid unser slogan the
future unsere wurst rheinsberger dann
schauen wir uns nach geschäftspartnern
und zulieferern um die firma so nack
gilt in der branche als gute adresse
wenn es darum geht schlachtabfälle zu
nutzen so nack wirbt auf seiner seite
mit bildern von gutem essen und
glücklichen tieren
und preist sich selbst als weltweit
führendes unternehmen bei der
wertschöpfung aus nebenprodukten wir
fragen uns was genau das eigentlich sein
soll
diese nebenprodukte und laden ein
vertreter der firma in unser angebliches
büro ein
der vertreter kommt ziemlich schnell zum
punkt wir sind ein entsorger wir holen
beim schlachthof alles ab was nicht
verarbeitet werden kann
wir verarbeiten 100% nichts landet bei
uns in der mülltonne
wir machen quasi aus scheiße gold das
ist ein geschäft mit dem macht man immer
geld
wie sieht das denn konkret aus zum
beispiel werden knochen zerkleinert und
enzymatisch aufgekocht bis der knochen
sich auflöst aus den bestandteilen zieht
man dann funktionelle eiweiß heraus
damit kriegen sie mehr wasser in die
wurst aus scheiße gold machen
dafür empfiehlt der vertreter ein
produkt besonders robust ein
funktionelles eiweiß
es kaschiert den hohen wasseranteil in
der wurst kontrolleure sollen ihn nicht
bemerken können und globus selbst ist
quasi nicht nachweisbar fliegt das bei
der lebensmittelkontrolle nicht auf klar
wenn ich weiß wo nachricht suchen will
oder suchen muss dann finde ich jedes
eiweiß aber der aufwand der nicht
betreiben muss um globus zu entdecken
der ist deutlich höher
das kann man einfach als natürliches
aroma kennzeichnen
wir wissen jetzt womit wir unsere wurst
strecken können aber vor allem brauchen
wir jemanden der uns hilft eine wurst
herzustellen
und das ist er franz-josef voll metzger
und ehemaliger lebensmittelkontrolleur
er weiß auch was zusatzstoffe wie globus
so attraktiv macht die einlagen wasser
ist leben die andere langwasser ist
kohle
es geht um geld es geht nur um geld wenn
wir uns jetzt vorstellen wir packen
unsere kleine chance drei liter wasser
da sagt der verbraucher daraus das ist
ja aber wenn ich 100 tonnen am tag mache
und packen dann 40 tonnen wasser da rein
dann kann man sich ungefähr vorstellen
was dann gespart und verdient wird das
ist unfassbar der verbraucher kauft im
grunde genommen schnittfestes wasser mit
unserem metzger vereinbaren wir globus
als zusatzmittel unserer wurst
beizumischen
zu demonstrationszwecken wir bestellen
bei so nack und bis unser paket ankommt
stehen wir weiter mit der firma so nack
in kontakt die laden uns sogar zu einem
seminar ein
wir geben uns als neuling am markt aus
der alles ganz genau wissen will
der trick funktioniert wir dürfen mit
unserem ipad film und bekommen exklusive
einblicke
zuerst geht es darum wasser ins
frischfleisch ein zu spritzen gepanscht
wird mit proteinen mit dem
eingespritzten protein wasser ist das
fleisch jetzt 15 bis 20 prozent schwerer
das sind unsere produkte die proteine
sind aus kollagen und die sind aus
plasma testet mal die wasser
bindungseigenschaften da geht es um
ausbeute also dass sich keine abschnitte
und fleisch verluste produzieren sondern
zu 100 prozent meine wahre benutzen kann
dann wird alles vermengt und in eine
hülle gepresst am nächsten tag wird das
ergebnis präsentiert die
zusammengeklebten reste halten dem
wackelt es stand und so nack auf
nachfrage erklärt der hersteller seine
produkte seien sicher und von hoher
qualität
außerdem müssten die fleischproduzenten
ihre ware korrekt deklarieren nachdem
sonax seminar schauen wir uns jetzt nach
der eigentlichen hauptzutat um fleisch
wir besuchen eine lebensmittelmesse und
geben uns als junges unternehmen aus
wir stoßen auf den stand der firma c&p
das unternehmen ist spezialisiert auf
zusatzstoffe
wir fragen nach wie wir an möglichst
billige fleischprodukte kommen ich würde
sagen die firma cernys kontaktieren von
den kriegt ihr alles der macht auch
separatoren fleisch separatoren fleisch
klingt eigenartig und ist es auch
eigentlich ist es gar kein fleisch
es wird aus schlachtabfällen hergestellt
in einem separat werden die knochen
regelrecht ausgedrückt es entsteht ein
brei der laut gesetz nicht mehr fleisch
genannt werden darf und gesondert
deklariert werden muss
auch wegen möglicher gesundheitsgefahren
trotzdem sind erhebliche mengen
separatoren fleisch im umlauf die
zuletzt verfügbaren zahlen von 2011
stammen von der eu kommission 100 30.000
tonnen separatoren fleisch fast die
hälfte wurde exportiert der rest
mindestens 68.000 tonnen wurde in
deutschland weiterverarbeitet
gerne wären wir der spur des separatoren
fleisches gefolgt doch von den firmen
ist nichts zu erfahren wo genau das
separatoren fleisch drin steckt
wir haben wirklich überall nachgefragt
wir haben die zuständigen behörden
gefragt die zuständigen ministerien wir
haben die systemgastronomie gefragt wir
haben die reparaturen fleisch
produzierende betriebe gefragt wir haben
wirklich überall nachgeforscht wo bleibt
denn diese reparaturen fleisch und alle
haben angegeben dies nicht zu verwenden
und eben die behörden um auch gesagt sie
wüssten nichts darüber wo diese
separatoren fleisch letztlich
verarbeitet wird
zurück auf der fleisch messe wir fragen
nach separatoren fleisch macht es sinn
mit separatoren fleisch zu arbeiten das
wort separatoren fleisch vergessen sie
mal ganz schnell das heißt in
deutschland 3 mm fleisch das macht
eigentlich jeder große -verarbeiter dass
er das rein macht man muss es nicht aufs
etikett schreiben
ich habe noch bei keinem großen gesehen
dass da irgendwas hinten drauf steht
kann separatoren fleisch einfach um
deklariert werden wir fragen offiziell
nach bei c&p die firma antwortet
schriftlich sie rät von separatoren
fleisch ab und teilt uns mit ob es sich
bei sogenannten 3 mm fleisch um
separatoren fleisch handelt muss der
produzent im einzelfall bewerten und
turniers der konzern ist der wohl größte
produzent von schweine separatoren
fleisch in deutschland und stellt auf
unsere nachfrage hin klar separatoren
fleisch müsse zwingend gekennzeichnet
werden und sei außerdem eine gute sache
wir sehen es als unsere pflicht an
fleisch das von einem nutzt hier stammt
auch bestmöglich zu verwenden zurück in
unserer firmenzentrale
endlich kommt ein paket der firma so nah
kann darin verschiedene funktionelle
proteine und globus das pulver das uns
angepriesen wurde um wasser zu
kaschieren
mit dem paket fahren wir zu unseren
gelernte metzgermeister und ehemaligen
lebensmittelkontrolleur voll alle für
unsere heutige wurstproduktion haben wir
vorbereitet reparaturen fleisch von
geflügel
das heißt also das ist wohl der letzte
rest der abfall
im grunde genommen ja noch verwertet
werden kann franz-josef voll kritisiert
seit jahren die industrielle produktion
von wurst und fleisch für uns macht er
eine wurst mit separatoren fleisch und
eiweißpulver hauptsache billig
dann haben wir hier das geflügelfleisch
das ist eine normale hähnchenbrust fest
wir sehen auch nicht wenn das schmilzt
da geht nichts ab im verhältnis zum
reparaturen fleisch das wird kritisch da
geht nicht ab so sollte das angeführt
die wurst seien voll sagt kein
ordentlicher metzgermeister würde mit
dem fleisch bei den billigen separatoren
fleisch arbeiten und dann gibt voll auch
noch unser sohn weiß pulver in die wurst
ich habe mit diesem pulver noch nie
gearbeitet
es fühlt sich auf den händen seltsam an
also wenn ich früher ein auto repariert
habe und hatte alten an den fingern war
das empfinden gleich man sieht auch wie
die haut glänzt aber vom gefühl her muss
ich sagen so hatte ich was mache bei mir
noch nie angefühlt
metzgermeister voll weiß was solche
pulver so attraktiv macht davon haben
die fleischer hunderttausend jahre
geträumt ich schütte wasser reise viel
wie ich will und das an findet es nicht
das heißt also wenn dieses pulver im
gaschromatographen verbrennt sagte ich
bin fleisch obwohl es gar kein fleisch
isst voll bereitet den fleisch breit zu
und macht wurst daraus widerwillig ich
mache das hier für demonstration ekelt
mich an so was zu machen
unsere gepanschte wurst muss jetzt nur
noch in heißem wasser geprüft werden die
fertige wurst wollen wir zur
qualitätsprüfung einreichen für das
gütesiegel der deutschen lebensmittel
gesellschaft kurz dlg sicherheit für den
verbraucher will dieses dlg siegel
bieten die dlg erklärt in ihrem
werbevideo die dlg auszeichnungen hat
eine hohe bedeutung im markt verbraucher
kennen dieses zeichen es ist ein
verlässliches zeichen für die qualität
von lebensmitteln
dlg siegel nur für wurst von besonders
hoher qualität das werden wir testen wir
verpacken unsere wurst sie besteht fast
zur hälfte aus separatoren fleisch und
fast einem drittel aus wasser fleisch
ist nur ganz wenig drin wird das bei den
strengen dlg labortests nicht auffliegen
ja keiner was wir machen
reparaturen fleisch ist analytisch
sowieso nicht nach wollte war
wir schicken unsere wurst an die dlg und
warten gespannt auf das ergebnis
nach einigen wochen post für unsere
scheinfirma die dlg beglückwünscht uns
zu unserem erfolg bei der
internationalen dlg-qualitätsprüfung
schinken und wurst 2018 für unsere
gepanschte wurst gibt es eine prämierung
der silberne dlg preis eine auszeichnung
für eine wurst nur zur 18 prozent aus
fleisch und speck besteht und deren
zutaten uns gerade mal 59 cent pro kilo
gekostet haben im supermarkt ließe sich
die wurst für mehr als sieben euro
verkaufen
ich finde gar keine worte für eigentlich
entsetzt mich dass so ein bisschen
wir haben wirklich will ich dieses wort
verwenden darf scheiße genommen das war
ja keine wurst dass das hat ja nicht mal
das hat ja man irgendwie berührt so eine
wolf herzustellen und wenn wir dann
trotzdem in der lage finden wir diesen
ganzen hilfsstoffen dafür eine medaille
zu bekommen dann ist das traurig dass
ich ein schlag ins gesicht für jeden
handwerker zum ende unseres fake wurst
experiments schauen wir mit der
prämierten wurst bei der dlg in
frankfurt vorbei die dlg wird unter
anderem von den großen unternehmen der
lebensmittelindustrie getragen und
möchte kein interview geben
schriftlich erklärt die dlg wenn gegen
die deg prüfbestimmungen verstoßen wird
führt dieser befund zum
prüfungsausschuss und zur aberkennung
einer dlg prämierung entdeckt hatte die
dlg die panscherei nicht sie hat sich
auf die herstellerangaben verlassen und
so konnten wir mit unserer scheinfirma
eine fake wurst herstellen mit ganz
wenig fleisch und ganz viel
zusatzstoffen eine wurst so billig wie
häufig im discounter was denkt ihr sind
wurst und fleisch einfach zu billig
schreibt es uns in die kommentare